your ranch
your rules
i fight how you say fight some people
are horrified by how dysfunctional our
family is and some people are enamored
with that but the reality is is exactly
what was written kevin costner opened up
about starring in the hit drama
yellowstone while walking the red carpet
with his wife at this year's sag awards
the iconic actor who plays john dutton
in the series looked back on the reasons
why the project appealed to him in the
first place i thought it had a chance to
be good i mean when i read it i and i
try to base my career
not on an audience
but on what i think has a level of
entertainment value and and then
if i think it does then i do think it
has a chance to resonate with an
audience if it kind of stays the way it
was written kevin also dished on his
upcoming western horizon which is a
project he's been working on for over a
decade it's something i've been trying
to make for about 10 years and it's a
it's it's just a really great storage
called horizon
and it's a american saga that um
you know it's uh
i just it i feel the same way as i've
talked about a lot of things i've done
that i've got a little secret in my
pocket
i need to go out there and make it
and if i if i don't mess it up it has a
chance to
live forever